Palestinian journalists in Gaza are not
just covering the war but they're also
living through it at least 109
Palestinian journalists have been killed
in the conflict so far the Palestinian
officials in Gaza say that that could be
much higher more than 50 media premises
or offices have been completely or
partially destroyed by Israeli strikes
and that includes the office of the AFP
Bureau in Gaza hundreds of Palestinian
journalists and their families including
our colleagues at Al jazer have been
forcibly displaced they've had to
abandon their reporting in offices in
the north to live and or to live and to
report under difficult conditions amidst
frequent communication blackouts
journalists working in areas of armed
conflict are protected under
International humanitarian law just like
civilians under the Geneva Convention
but Israel has been accused of violating
those rules of law repeatedly
Palestinian journalists say Israel is
trying to kill the messenger and silence
the
story Antoine Bernard is the director of
advocacy at report Without Borders and
joins us now from Paris another
journalist death another high-profile
death which just highlights uh as as we
said the highest number of journalists
ever killed in such a short period of
time in a violent
conflict yes indeed and um Let me please
first say that we are reporters Without
Borders are in real shock after this uh
uh again U um murder of journalist and
and and the death of Mustafa Taya and
Hamza dhu um journalist for AFP
journalist for Al jazer it appears
according to our information uh that the
car in which they were killed was
directly targeted and a single rocket
fell directly on their car this is what
we're investigating right now if such
was the case it would be it would
qualify as another War crime against
journalists in Gaza uh for arsa 79
journalists killed in Gaza since 7
October it's indeed what we call in
French an eom a massive Slaughter and
this has to stop it's easy to make the
demands isn't it Mr Ben
many organizations humanitarian groups
journalist groups have have asked for a
ceasefire have demanded a ceasefire the
public at large globally have at what
stage do you take this forward in your
organization you collect all the
evidence until what time can you then
present it to people in power that can
do something about
it well from day one in fact rsf started
uh taking uh all the information
collected daily on crimes against
journalists to people in power more than
that uh We've triggered with formal
criminal complaints the international
criminal court as soon as 31st October
with a first complaint and a second one
filed on 22nd December we claim at a
minimum war crimes have being
perpetrated against journalists in Gaza
as I was saying according to rsf figures
79 journalists killed among whom
according again to our
investigation 14 were killed in action
in action and some of them uh we fear
and we have reasonable grounds to
believe have been intentionally targeted
intentionally Target targeted and that
may be the case for mustafaa and ham
dardu like it has been the case for well
D we fear on 15 December last um let me
take the opportunity to really say and
pay tribute and admiration for the AL
jazer team in general and for well D in
particular after what he's been and
today going through uh the the the death
of his wife his three kids now himself
being wounded on 15 December this is
heroic journalism really from where you
are
sir in
Paris where you are in Paris uh do you
think the world cares do you think that
that organized that the media cares
where you
are of course of course the media where
we are rsf is present in the whole world
headquarters in Paris with offices in
all regions and I can confirm and
testify that the world carries uh Europe
carries France cares but rsf does care
and we are all mobilized uh 7 247 like
today uh to be able to to react uh and
uh and to and to help and to support uh
the Palestinian journalists thank to
thanks to whom uh the world can watch
but the price they pay is much too heavy
this should not happen it's a massacre
it's an unbearable Massacre of
journalist Israel is eradicating
journalism in Gaza we will continue to
refer to the international criminal
court all the cases so that maximum
priority is given by the prosecutor of
the ICC to crimes against journalists
especially the crimes happening in Gaza
now are just without precedent this has
to stop an Bernard from reporters
Without Borders thank you sir for
joining us from Paris